hi my name is Sandra chambers a pot
tailor chambers and I'm tired and afraid
30 mil church then Cody also just saw
two as well like this the whole time
we're on the movie game we wanted to
make it like a classical gang name so
like ghosts and ghosts enough stress
something so we're calling us up ghosts
to movies
I'm not co-signing it we all agreed no
we didn't so we just watched alien
covenants I loved whew I thought I was
super fun people have been like I was
gonna say pooh-poohing it at one point
at one point David does ask Walter why
do you do it and he says facehugger but
laughter oh I thought it was a blast
people have been saying that it's just
like every other alien film but I like
every other alien film so I was totally
cool with it I thought it did a good job
of kind of combining the elements of the
first two like is the you know cuz I
keep the horror and then you have like
the science-fiction action aspect of the
first two movies were like that's kind
of what separates them like the original
original I liked that it was kind of a
mix of horror and then the action space
kind of Ripley aspects of it
I wish the recorder scene had been
longer
I was really disappointing also the
title scene where the title of the movie
comes on was way too quick like I you
know
on there for 13 minutes and I was like I
don't know if I could read all of it I
like this poison Milania yeah decent
lines for about a minute yeah oh yeah
and then like 13 minutes of looking at
the title of space and I was like I
don't know if I can read all of these
letters individually in time and I
luckily it was just managed I just
managed to make it yeah opening scene
between David and his creator was just
like can we get it we get what's
happening we understand I agree with you
on the split between the sci-fi and
horror aspects I think are great it's
like exactly what I want a movie I want
to be scary I wants to be sci-fi I want
to take place in space I want there to
be an awesome lead actress who's just
super strong who lives throughout the
whole thing yeah hell yeah I want James
Franco to die immediately my favorite
part of the movie my favorite part is
I'm not lying my favorite part of the
movie is that James Franco dies
immediately my least favorite part of
the movie is that they still made me
watch James Franco afterwards so that
was disappointing they killed him before
I even knew was James Franco and that
was great do I know that she got
anywhere I'm pretty sure in a picture
later he's wearing a poncho in space
which he deserved Jesus well yeah there
was a little space Jesus for sure it was
like Last Supper space Jesus yes we mean
Jesus I'm starting that conspiracy I'm
not starting that I'm pretty sure that's
a thing that's Jesus can you do some odd
religious aspects yeah I get it
it's the key what are the characters
yeah I think they're trying to tie it
all and like the creation aspect so I
think that was kind of where that was
kind of coming from but it was a little
I the problem was with with one
character specifically that aspect
wasn't really followed through on as
much like it was kind of mentioned
periodically it's almost like they might
have cut scenes where it was where it
was worth prevalent and relevant means
yeah it impacts where is this where they
were just telling us that this character
was religious
right alright it was like well that's
fine this is a spaceship that is
entirely staffed by couples that was
part of it yeah I think it's because
when they get there they're gonna see a
column yeah and there's only 2,000
people left and yeah you want going in I
knew that that was the case that they
were all couples from the trailers I
think this is gonna be such a
heartbreaking movie you know like not
all these Jews they're gonna live like
damn she's never seen a horror movie I
thought the movie was like really pretty
like visually gorgeous oh yeah it was
like beautifully horrific though yeah
yeah like that wall of like people
climbing over each other that are just
like charred and Fox's great yeah
they've definitely done a really good
job of kind of evolving on Giger's
original designs and stuff and kind of
still keeping it and moving it forward
but it's still kind of creating kind of
a newer like you know like like a like a
next generation the style kind of
changes to it yeah just let it stagnate
but link building on top yeah aliens are
still keeping the same feeling while
evolving is obviously a lot of this is
about to be a shoot and evolving so that
is nice yeah I'll never look at a head
floating in water the same way again
that is that that changed a lot for me
what is your favorite alien gentleman -
aliens I've seen them so it's probably
the original alien alien yeah well I
mean I really like that one but like I
like the original - like it well loads
so I'm probably gonna say yeah
aliens is my fav I like I like Lockheed
Evan stuff sometimes so this is gonna
this is gonna be all of the anger from
everyone but I like alien versus
Predator we were talking about on the
way too
like it's it's not great but it's so fun
I knew what I was getting into when I
went there it was other things all right
I'm here yeah like that's it and I like
predator a lot to be fair so like that
added to my fairy tale Ian movie is the
movie that had predator in it predator
have been the boss baby I would have
been okay yeah there are some things
that happen that we're just kind of
funny and funny and there's no way you
could watch a test screening of that and
not realize how funny it is yeah they
they literally just be like suddenly
watch of lions I imagine like when
you're in the bank and you send the
money up the tube gonna go though yep
yep it was just like they're like
they're having a funeral and then they
just go alright following see I was
cracking up there's some like yeah
there's some like weird moments like
that where it's just like how could you
not have seen that as funny there's a
whole thing that's a part redeem it
there's a recorder scene which as I said
was not long enough but David's teaching
Walter how to use a recorder and he goes
all finger the holes and I'm like come
on that was great he has a really
magnetic personality because it's a
robot
no cadiz magneto Oh
[Applause]
the Farion thing was just like super
predictable at a point and it was kind
of like it would have been nice if there
had been like a little bit of a surprise
aspect to it or something because it's
like the it wasn't even dramatic irony
necessarily like the characters figure
it out and we like and the anybody would
have figured that out you know ten
twenty minutes earlier but the way that
they accomplished like the action in the
ending I was really exciting the the
lead girl was like outrageously good
like I oh my god one wants to act with
her to want to see her at everything
three want to kiss her face when you
kiss her are you gonna use your normal
mouth or your tiny alien mouth my
favorite person to be with Diane Keaton
I thought she was fantastic in this
movie because she is definitely in it
there was one moment that was just that
you guys are talking about this where
it's so obvious that you shouldn't do
that the character did it I was like I
mean you come on man it had a couple of
those horror movie tropes where it's
like no rational person would act that
way in this situation even under the
duress even under that kind of stress
especially if you're a trained person in
this it in like these situations you
know it's just like that too many people
it's fun if like one time that happens
or something but there are too many
people making too many bad decisions
that were just like come on all right
I like how it is his best creation is
like a super throwback to like the prime
alien it's just like classic ass alien
and I thought that that was really cool
that they're like oh this is like the
apex aliens yeah yeah also a side note I
really want to share with that classic
like a ghost in the shell' he was
actually he was a ghost edition
oh I wanted to say that I thought that
the guy could played the new captain
forgot his name
yeah Michael the Christian guy he's a
[Laughter]
totally well I was like fearing for my
life visibility cameras just you say
Cody I'm not saying you're trying I'm
not saying yes we're I really want an
alien to burst out of my chest right now
I think that's the perfect ending
[Music]